thank you very much tom
good afternoon everybody i would like to
welcome you all to this virtual meeting
of audit and governance on
tuesday the 22nd of september
2020 i will just go through some of the
basic rules
for this meeting at the start of the
meeting we will mute all microphones
except for mine the chairs please leave
all microphones muted unless you are
asked to speak
by me to indicate
to me that you would like to speak or
propose
or second emotion please press raise the
hand
symbol in the participants menu on your
screen
these are shown on my screen in the
order that they are pressed
and i will deal with them in order
giving the appropriate officer or cancer
the opportunity to answer in between
where necessary
i will also return to the counsellor to
check that they are happy with the
response
to ensure clarity and accuracy during
the virtual meetings
all votes will be cast via a verbal
recorded vote
and names will be read out in
alphabetical order
please state your vote clearly and
slowly
when your name is read out unmuting
and muting your microphone as necessary
please remember to ensure full
transparency
with the democratic process this meeting
is being
live streamed on the council's youtube
channel
we are in unprecedented times and i ask
you
all to be patient during this meeting
and to understand
that processes and advice may take
longer than usual
now onto our main agenda and item one
apologies for absence
do we have any apologies for absence for
this meeting
yes thank you chair apologies received
from councillor rossi however councillor
james
is substituting thank you thank you
thank you very much kirsty and thank you
very much cancer james for coming in at
short notice
yeah i'm sorry chair because i've had
something else come up
and so i'm gonna have to leave the
meeting at ten to three i'm really sorry
um that's fine that's one thing after
another at the moment
i can i can fully understand and thank
you for letting me know thank you
um item two
minutes pages 4 to 15
i'll confirm the minutes of the meeting
held on the 28th of july 2020
so if we just do a quick page turner
pages four five
six seven
eight nine
10 11
12 13
14 and finally page 15.
does anybody wish to make a comment or
second or
if i'm happy to propose from the chair
i'm looking for a seconder for the
minutes please
counselor craig you have your hand up uh
do you wish to second
yeah thank you very much indeed so we
have a proposal from the second uh
um i'll pass you back to kirsty for
taking the vote
thank you thank you very much chair
councillor craigie
or councillor heppel
or councillor hudson
or councillor james
abstain councillor james
four so that's
five four and one abstention chair
thank you kirsty we'll now move on to
the third item which is the action list
which is found on page 16.
um chris would you be happy to work
through the action list
yeah i can do that sure thank you um
the first one there is to invite mark
gaming to the meeting
he's actually on today's agenda doing a
presentation on the pension scheme
so that one's done um the second action
is to do with the
information sharing protocol for
safeguarding uh steve have you got an
update on that one
uh yes thanks um so just an update on
that so
uh mark williams is no longer um our
district rep i need to find out who's
replaced him
um obviously we've had some internal uh
changes at charge as well so simon who
was the customer services
uh lead manager and leads is no longer
in place either
stacey dory's our current uh
safeguarding lead
so we just we still need to establish um
with deb and audit partnership whether
this is still required so
um chair if you're happy we'll bring
that forward to the next meeting
yes i'm happy with that thank you steve
um the next one's got my
name against it as well to produce a
maintenance plan for the harbor to
address
issues raised um i think that action's
actually been captured
wrong i think it's
in relation to improvements around
how the harbor can be used rather than
maintenance issues and maintenance plans
so it's about development of the harbour
as a kind of acid rather than as
physical maintenance problems um so i
would suggest
that uh that particular action is
referred to the harbour board
for consideration so if we can
action that and put it on the
i'll put it to the chair of the harbour
board for inclusion
as a an action for the next harbour
board meeting
okay that would seem appropriate yes
council hodgson you wish
claire
um you have your hand up claire
no yes i've got i hadn't unmuted myself
could i just ask um this maintenance
plan for the harbour
was it not about um the
crane and the uh continuing
servicing of it as a
a piece of equipment that was very
rarely used
and i believe there was some discussion
with regard to
should we be keeping it should we be
maintaining it
um should we be hiring in the equipment
when we needed it
i seem to recall that it wasn't about
necessarily
the development of the harbour
but more about the actual things that
service the
harbour correct me if i'm wrong please
um okay i think i think it's yeah i
think i might have picked up such a
range of things isn't it
harbor what we on the bottom of page
seven
[Music]
um i'd reported back that the harbour
board reports the community resources
on particular matters in relation to the
harbour
so that the same would have would apply
anyway so i can see that going over on
page eight
talks about um
um harvard repair maintenance or we do
inspection so
again it's something for the harbour
board to consider
so all those items in the minutes there
should be
referred to the harbour board the
consideration
okay thank you steve castle craig you
have your hand up uh would you like to
speak uh thank you
and it was in relation to that i mean
what i raised the problem that
it was highlighted in the audit that the
the management of the harbour wasn't
satisfactory because there was a number
of
mission reports and a missing
certificate overdue inspections
etc can we have a report back from the
harbour
committee if we're going to just refer
it to the harbour committee
can they report to us on how they're
improving it because
we're responsible for the order aren't
we and if the audit
is telling us that it's not up to
standard then it's not you just to make
sure it is
okay yes well we'll report that as the
the issue
to the harbour board and we'll ask them
to consider the items
in the audit report um if there are any
changes proposed that would need to go
through
community and resources we know
i've now changed some of the harbor
responsibilities so richard haste is
currently
responsible for the the management of
the overall management of the harbour
obviously we've got um staff responsible
for
the details within that so we can then
bring
the considerations of the harbour board
back to
audit governance so what they've
considered what actions they consider
taking place
uh we can report that back to this
committee as well
thank you right
thank you very much steve that would be
an appropriate way going forward to
make sure that we can uh look at the
results on that
right um yes back to you chris
yeah just finally on the the social
value policy
that has actually been completed um the
actual climate term
change group is going to actually look
at responsible procurement
and how it applies a tourist so that
documents not going to be referred to
the climate change group
before it gets formally adopted so that
one's kind of still ongoing
that's it chair thank you very much
chris
right we now move on to item four which
is the declaration of interests
members with interest should refer to
the agenda item and describe the nature
of their interest
when the item is considered
item five agreement of agenda items part
one and two this afternoon we do not
have a part two
item six urgent matters of information
to be brought forward with the
permission of the chair
i have none
item seven pension fund presentation
mark galef from demon county council to
present
the pension investment strategy so um
over to you mark yes good afternoon
hopefully you can all hear me
okay um i've put together a presentation
um which will appear on the screen and
i'll go through it
and i'll try and go through things quite
quickly there's a
various different aspects i could
concentrate on i'm not sure
which you're going to be most interested
in so um
happy to take questions at the end um
we move on to the next slide
um so this is just an overview so
devon county council acts as the
administering authority of
of the fund currently we manage assets
of um well about four and a half billion
pounds
as at the 30th of june it's it's gone up
since the the end of march
when when it had gone down quite a bit
because of the
impact of the the pandemic so we have
over 200
employers paying into the fund which
includes torridge
um district council along with with the
other um
councils around devon plus um
a number of contractors who do work for
councils and
all the different school academies each
count as
a separate employer to the fund and we
have over 125
000 members of the scheme which includes
people paying in
people who are receiving their pension
and people who um
have built up a pension which they're
not yet taken but they're not any longer
paying into it
and we invest our money into a range of
investments and i'll go
go through that as as we go through
move on to the next slide
every year we publish an annual report
um you can find the one for 2018-19
online
we haven't yet published the 2019-20
annual report normally we would have
done so by now but
because of the pandemic i'm sure you
probably have a similar situation the
audit of our accounts is taking a lot
longer than usual
um deadlines have been extended so that
that's not yet
um available but will be published um
in november if you move on to the next
slide
um this just shows how the the fund has
built up
over the years so if you go back to 2007
the size of the fund was about 2.2
billion
and it has um
grown by about to about double since
since then
um the arrows you can see and for some
reason the
the dates that above the arrows have not
come out quite right and i thought they
were
right when i sent it but never mind um
they
indicate the years where we have
actuarial valuations
and that's a crucial time because that's
the point at which we assess
the the funding level and how we're
doing as a fund in terms of having
enough assets to meet our liabilities
and
depending where those valuations take
place
could impact both the funding level and
indeed um the contributions that we ask
each of our employers to make
so if you look at back at 2019
then we were in a good place um
at the end of march 2020 our assets has
gone down
remarkably so we're fortunate we weren't
having to
um set a new round of contributions
based on that position
it's recovered since then but obviously
we still live in
uncertain times so so over the 2019-20
year we actually
had a negative performance of minus 8
because of the the impact of the
pandemic on global markets
since the end of march the fund's gone
up by 11.4
so that's much better news as as markets
have rallied
since then and over the last 10 years
we've we've achieved on average a return
of 5.4
each year next slide
so every three years we do an actuarial
valuation
that looks at the position of the fund
whether we have enough assets to meet
our liabilities
and that then influences the level of
contributions we ask
you as a council and all the other
employers to pay
going forward and what the actuaries do
for us at that at each valuation is they
assess
um how much we're likely to have to pay
out over each of the next
well if you look there 75 to 80 years
for people
currently in the scheme
in terms of pension liabilities they've
already built up
so if you look at the light blue
hump as it were what that shows is that
gradually more people will
retire and therefore we will have to pay
out more pensions
and then when you get past the peak
of that hump that's where
in effect you've got more people coming
out of the scheme because unfortunately
they're
dying um then we've got
new pensioners coming into the scheme
based on those who are in the scheme at
the moment and the
actually then calculates how much
pension
we're probably going to have to pay for
the next 75 to 80 years for people
currently in the scheme so imagine that
if we've got an employee who's 20 at the
moment
then if they live to 100 they could
still be receiving their pension in 80
years time
but then we make investment returns on
the assets we've got
so we don't need the full amount of that
light blue hump
as assets of the fund now because we
will build those up
so that actually discounts them and
comes
to what's the darker blue line which is
what are the assets that we need
now um if we're going to meet those
liabilities
and that 14 billion and the three and a
half billion emotional figures
as at a point in time uh they don't
reflect where at the moment but it just
gives you the general
um concept so if we move to the next
slide
this shows the the position that the
actuary
has has determined um so
the across the total of the fund
across devon we've got assets of um
the actually assessed at the 31st of
march 2019 as
4 million to 4 billion 273 million
and when they calculated the liabilities
using sort of the methods that i've just
described
then they think that we have live
estimated liabilities of
4.67 billion so therefore we've got a
shortfall on that of about 400 million
but that's come down since the three
years before
so that's good news because we've got a
long time
to to make sure that we've got enough
liability
assets to meet our liabilities we don't
have to have it now but we do have
to plan for building it up to
being 100 funded which is why then we
charge deficit contributions
to each of the employ employers then on
the right hand side you've got the
position for torridge council
um which is you know each employer
has their own sort of share of the
assets and their own share of the
liabilities based on
their employees and ex-employees who are
in the scheme
and your position is not quite as good
as the average position for the whole
fund
and that means that you are paying a
higher deficit contributions
than than the average but i think they
still went down
from the previous valuation which is is
good news
so that that's one thing that you would
be interested in
and based on that position is the
contribution rates that you have to meet
as an authority
for this year next year and the year
after
um as well as doing
this valuation the actual also has to do
a separate valuation of
liabilities for your accounts and they
do that in a different
way that's prescribed by accounting
regulations
and so the deficit that will appear in
your statement of accounts is probably a
lot bigger
than what is shown there but essentially
from the pension funds point of view
what's in your accounts is a notional
figure
based on accounting rules but the real
deficit in terms of
what we need you to meet going forward
is the one shown
here if we move on
next slide um we have to
have an investment strategy statement
that sets out what our investment
strategy is in order to
build up our assets and make sure that
we have enough
assets to meet all the pension
liabilities going forward and i'm just
gonna
talk a little bit more about that so if
we move on to the next
slide within that investment strategy we
have to show
asset allocation so we split our assets
between
equities bonds property
infrastructure allocations and that just
shows it's
quite difficult to take it in quickly
but all the different types of assets
that we
invest in it works out that we're we're
about 58
of our funds are in equities shares in
companies
about 13 in bonds and
10 in commercial property
8 in infrastructure assets and then
11 in something called diversified
growth funds which tries to
um allocate across a variety of
different sorts of things
and then to try and um move things
around to reflect where they think the
markets are going to go
um so we're invested in equities that
shares on the stock market because
they can give us a much better return
and giving us a much better return
make sure that we keep your contribution
rates down but there is a
more of a risk in those as if the
markets
go down dramatically as they did in
march
time um then we lose a lot of value
and so we do have other assets to try
and shore the fund up
at those times of distress but we still
need to
maintain that high risk in order to
um get the returns that we need
next slide please
um one thing that we've been doing since
2015 is the government
have asked us to pool our investments
with
other um lgps funds in order to try and
um achieve cost savings so
we formed with nine other local
government pension
scheme funds the brunel pension
partnership
and they now manage the bulk of our
investments
so next slide
this just shows you the different pools
that have been set up across the country
across the england and wales we are part
of the brunel pool
which is the orangey color
and shows you our partner funds within
that pool
so our assets are now combined
with devon cornwall with avon
dorset cornwall buckinghamshire
oxfordshire etc
um and what that means is that instead
of
where we might invest 200 million in
emerging markets
um and we would previously have
appointed a fund manager to manage that
we can now combine the 200 million we
want to put into emerging markets is
what the other
councils want to put in emerging markets
and then
that means that a much bigger sum
say a billion or two billion can be
um invested which means that we're able
to
negotiate down the fees that we have to
pay to the fund managers to manage that
because they're managing
uh more for us so you get economies of
scale
and that that was the the basis of the
government's pooling proposals
next slide
so we set up through now pension
partnership as a company they're
set up as a company in which we hold 10
of the shares along with our partner
funds they have a company board
lots of staff who manage all these
investments on our behalf
so they do have a that does present an
overhead that we didn't have before
but the savings that they're able to
make on the fees more
should more than pay for that that extra
cost of
having created the brunel partnership
there is an oversight board which
includes the chair of our pensions
committee and the
nine other pension committee chairs who
oversee that as a effectively a type of
scrutiny
committee looking up what brunella are
doing
and making sure that they're delivering
what we want them to deliver
the next slide
this just shows how we've transitioned
our assets across to them
so it's the same chart as you saw before
you will see that some things have been
transitioned across to them
some things still haven't so we've still
got
um bonds that we're managing or we have
our own fund managers to manage outside
of brunel but eventually those will
transition
across to brunel along with everything
else
next slide
one of the things we have to do with our
investments is is that we want to be
responsible investors which means that
um as we own shares in companies
we should be responsible owners of of
those companies
um what what that means is that
we have to manage risk as well because
if companies are doing things that they
shouldn't do
then their share price in the end is not
going to
benefit from that and that means that
our investments might go down so as
responsible investors we have to manage
the risks associated with with our
investments to make sure we're investing
in companies
that have a sustainable financial future
to generate returns
um for us to meet our objectives
now what that means in practice
is that um that there are a wide range
of things that you could consider on an
ethical basis
including investing in fossil fuels
investing in tobacco investing in fast
food companies
investing in companies that might employ
labor with practices that aren't very
good
and if you look at all the different
ethical
issues you could consider you might end
up
being able to invest in very little at
all because there's
problems with just about every company
that you could go into if you looked at
it in
um to its utmost
so we don't as a fund
not invest in things for ethical reasons
on the whole
but what we do do is manage those risks
and then talk
to those companies about what they're
doing and try and make sure
that they are managing things in in a
better way
um so i'm going to concentrate on
climate change
for a couple of minutes because that's
the subject that most people are
interested in at the moment outside of
the pandemic which is another issue in
itself
next slide please
um so we we are in members of various
different bodies
so we're members of the international
investors group on climate change
um so that that means that we're part of
a group that's
taking action on behalf of investors in
relation to climate change
we're members of the local authority
pension fund forum who represent
all local authority pension funds or not
all of them but all the
ones who are members of that
organization which is
um at least three quarters of them
and they will actually go and talk to
these companies on our behalf
about about what they're doing next
slide please
um so we expect our investment managers
to take um
environmental social and governance
issues into account when they make
investment decisions
we expect them to engage we expect them
to vote at company meetings
and where we've now pooled our resources
and set up the brunel pension
partnership they're also doing a lot of
work on our behalf
in making sure that all of this
engagement activity
is is done properly and we're also
looking
at how we try and make sure that
companies are working
towards alignment with the objectives of
the paris agreement on climate change
as well because that's that's important
to us
next slide please
so in our investment strategy statement
we say that we recognize that climate
change will have impacts across our
portfolio so we look to the brunel
partnership
and all our asset managers to identify
and manage climate
related financial risks as part of
day-to-day fund management
and we are looking for our investment
portfolios
to reduce in terms of their carbon
intensity
as as time goes on both by what we're
invested in but also
talking to the companies and encouraging
them to
um aim to reduce their carbon footprints
next slide please
so again as i said it we don't favor
blanket disinvestment we we think that
actually
it if you take a company like shell um
obviously they they are an oil company
fossil fuel company
um we could decide that we don't invest
in them at all
but what we would rather do is actually
keep some shares in them
and then try and influence their
behavior
because they can play a big part in the
transition to a zero carbon economy if
they are
doing work on developing um
alternative energy sources different
fuels
whatever um which they are doing and if
we can
manage to get them to divert more of
their energy into that type of activity
and away from their traditional oil
activity
then that will actually in in our view
make a difference in terms
of dealing with climate change whereas
if we just sold our shares
to someone who probably doesn't care
about those issues
um then there's nobody banging on the
door and saying look you've got to
change the way you
manage your company so
we have our differences of opinion with
certain groups who would
prefer that we just got rid of all of
our shares
in in oil companies but we take a
different view at the same time we have
to make sure that we are managing the
risks associated with that
um that where you've potentially got
companies that are dependent on that
type of business
that might lose value on those shares
because
of the way that we transition our
society
then we we need to make sure that we're
we're taking those risks into account as
well
because what we're aiming for is to make
sure always
that we're achieving the best return we
can for
our fund members to make sure that they
get the pension that they deserve when
they retire
next slide please
and part part of the way we do this is
we measure
our carbon footprint and we've
first time we did this was going back to
march 2019
and this shows our equity holdings
and shows what the carbon footprint of
it
was so for the total fund at that time
um the estimate was that the companies
we were invested in
um effectively gave off 423
tons of carbon um for every million
pounds invested and that's what the
weighted average carbon intensity
measures um some portfolios that we're
invested in
are higher we have an investment in
emerging markets
um companies who work in emerging
markets probably have lower standards
than in other parts of the world and
therefore
their carbon footprint is higher
but from a financial point of view we're
also benefiting from the
higher growth that you see in those
types of economies so
we wouldn't want to disinvest from
emerging markets but we would want to
try and work with the companies
involved to try and reduce their carbon
footprint if you move on to the next
slide
which shows that doing it
doing the same exercise at the 31st of
december
we'd actually saw a reduction of 21.5
in the funds carbon footprint between
march and december 2019 part of that
is where we've transitioned funds um
across to brunel who
have taken a much more proactive view to
trying to make sure that um companies
are
managing their climate change risks um
and therefore that helped to reduce the
carbon footprint but also i think
companies are working on it and it shows
that
the engagement efforts that we're making
with companies is helping to reduce
their carbon footprint and we are aiming
we have a target to reduce that carbon
footprint by a further seven percent
each year for the next two years
then we will effectively audit
what we've done and what we want to do
going forward um in terms of setting
um that target going forward
with the aim of achieving um
net zero carbon by 2050
so next slide please
brunel have a climate change policy you
can find that on on the web
which shows how how they're managing um
the impacts of climate change on our
behalf
next slide please
just quick summary we we are long-term
investors we can look
as i said somebody who works for us
who's 20 now
will still be receiving their pension in
potentially 80 years time so we've got a
long term to look at we don't have to
make decisions based on short-term
um requirements we can look at the
longer term
we we are
working to make sure that we can where
your contributions coming in they're now
often less than the
pension benefits we pay out in a year so
we have to manage our strategy to deal
with that
but that's not really an issue for us
because we have investment income that
can
bridge that gap um we're pooling our
investments as i've already talked about
and we're really looking to manage it
for the long term
so that we can we've got the assets
there
to meet the pension needs of our pension
fund members but trying to do it
at um a cost that is acceptable
to our employers and ultimately to the
taxpayers
so that's it happy to answer any
questions
thank you very much indeed mark does
anybody wish to
ask any questions
no counselor craigie i think you wanted
to
ask didn't you ruth i can see you yes
ask away put my hand up yeah don't worry
i can see you
thank you um
there's such an a lot of questions in my
mind it's
hard to sort of concentrate on the most
important
at the at the end you said you're
working towards 2050 to be carbon
net zero is that the devon county
council's policy
to be net zero by 2050
i i i believe i i think it is um
we we have to have our we have our own
policies
as a pension fund um we we want to align
with that and um i think devon
is probably in terms of its operations
trying to do it quicker than that
and certainly in terms of any carbon
footprint of
the the sort of team that manages the
pensions on behalf of devon
we would be um looking to be in line
with
with the council's targets in terms of
investments i think it's it's more
difficult
because you're relying on all the
companies
that you're invested in to be managing
their um
funds appropriately but i think in terms
of the objectives of the paris agreement
where i think we're looking um to
in terms of that two-degree scenario to
keep it to that
and and and i think the 2050 is
where we're aiming at to try and align
ourselves with the paris agreement
my second question is on the where
you've got the
what all the investments were and then
you've got the target
for this year coming um you've got
sustainable equities
you haven't got anything in but your
target was to have something in
i was wondering uh why you haven't got
any yet
and what what are you looking at to
invest in
right so um sustainable equities
is i i talked a lot about setting up the
brunel pension partnership
and effectively what's happening is is
our investments are transferring over to
to brunel as they set up portfolios so
when we set them up what they had to do
was a whole set of procurement exercises
to appoint managers to manage different
types of investment portfolios
for us and brunel's other clients so
their sustainable equities portfolio is
due to launch
at the end of this month and when it
launches we will be putting
some of our resources our targeted level
as per that chart into into that
so if i came back to you in three months
time
then i could say to you that we would
have we would have by that time
invested within that portfolio
essentially what it's looking at
is um a portfolio that
comprises of companies that are um
taking more action to do with climate
change it wouldn't include
things like oil companies um so
it is particularly targeting um
companies that that are seen as being
more sustainable
and doing the right thing from an
environmental
and social point of view for society
um and as i say we will be putting money
in as soon as that portfolio is launched
which is due
at the end of this month well
that's good that's good news um
but uh with all these new
the new people that we're having to get
through to run all these investment
portfolios
in brunel is it has there been um a
reduction in staff
at the devon county council pension fund
bit
um or is it i'm just wondering if we're
just adding another layer and we're
getting more
more and more stuff i think it i i think
that it is adding another layer we we
did make some savings
a couple of years ago um
when we reviewed our our staffing levels
with within the the team but
um there's still a lot that we have to
do so
while brunel effectively
effectively brunel appoint fund managers
to manage these assets on our behalf
we still as a pension fund have the
responsibility for deciding what sort of
assets we
want so if i if go back to your example
of the sustainable equities portfolio
brunel will appoint managers to manage
that on our behalf but if we decided
that we didn't want to put anything in
that portfolio
then that's that's our decision not
theirs we have to decide
as a pension fund which of the
20 pots that brunel provides essentially
we want to put our money into
so we still have to manage the strategy
of that we still have to
oversee the job that they're doing for
us to make sure that they're
doing what we want them to do so there's
still a
level of resource quite a reasonable
level of resource required
at the dev and pension fund to make sure
that the fund is managed effectively
so yes you could say that the creation
of brunel has
created an overhead that wasn't there
before
has added extra cost that wasn't there
before
but the aim of that is to make sure that
things are more effectively managed to
reduce risk to some degree
and also as i said to reduce and
negotiate down the fees that we have to
pay
to the investment management companies
such such as um legal in general
to just to name one that we can reduce
down their fees by
more in total than the cost that it's
cost us
to set up brunel and therefore make
the savings for the for the fund
so although it isn't overhead it's it's
an in
an investor saved type policy you might
say
yeah thanks um but so we can influence
uh what the pension fund invests in can
we how do we do that
if you if you have a devon strategy how
do we influence the devon
strategy well we run
a number of events over the year well a
couple of events
that are important so each year we have
an employer's meeting
which we will present to and
um the employer meeting you have the
opportunity to ask
questions put forward points of view
we will answer those questions and
if if we feel that that there's things
that need to be done as a result of
um influence from from employers then
then we can do that equally
once the year we have a meeting that is
open to all pension fund members
to come to we um
as well as well in the past we've had
that as a meeting that people can attend
that might be tricky next time because
of the current situation but even
then we also webcast it so that anybody
could watch it
um give people the chance of of having
their stating their point of view um
so we people can write to us
people do write to us um and we try and
answer their questions but you you can
be assured that we are
doing our best to um
manage the funds effectively we have a
fiduciary responsibility to make sure
we're achieving the best risk adjusted
returns we can
to make sure that we can afford all
these pensions going forward
um and and managing some of the risks
involved is is important doing that
including
the the types of risks related to
climate change and other issues
yeah the major risk that i can see is
the carbon bubble bursting and all your
shares being worthless
indeed and that's something that we are
we
we would expect to be to be managed on
our behalf
thank you on a different matter i
noticed that
um torridge is slower than average in
um the amount of contributions that can
well the deficit in our contributions
is that any concern to you or are you
happy with the situation that we're in
i think i think the important thing is
that it is that
it's getting better um as i said
we we need to when the actuary is
looking
at our position he's sort of projecting
ahead and saying that if you've got
someone who's 20 on your payroll now um
then effectively they're including a
liability for us to pay their pension
sort of 40 50 years into the future
when they might start receiving a
pension and
up to 80 is when they will finish
receiving their
receiving their pension potentially so
although
um we as a fund are not 100
funded for all our liabilities you as a
an employer are
less funded for all of your liabilities
um
some of those liabilities aren't going
to be required to be met and
for many many many years into the future
so as long as we have a plan
to get you up to that 100 funded
position which
we do and that's why you pay deficit
contributions then i don't think it's
too much of a concern um
but it needs to continue on that sort of
upward path
to make sure that when the actually does
their review in
another three years time they not
suddenly deciding that you need to pay a
lot more
into the fund to meet your liabilities
thank you that's all my questions i'd
just like to say thank you very much for
coming and how helpful it's been and how
very interesting it's been
thank you thank you
does anybody else wish to make any
comment or have any questions
no i've got um several brief questions
very briefly
um who are your auditors and
when will the audit be concluded for
this year
our auditors are grant thornton um
as to when it's going to be concluded i
it certainly hasn't yet i i'm not
entirely
sure but um
clearly we we still have some deadlines
that we have have to meet
um i promised the investment and pension
fund committee that they will get
the annual report um to approve at their
next meeting
on the 27th of november the councils
that the pension fund accounts also form
part of devon county council's accounts
and the devon county council audit
committee meets
um in the first half of november i think
so the audit will have to be completed
by then
right okay thank you very much and
just my final question um
it refers back to ruth's um casa
craigie's
last question the reason why we have a
a deficit is it because our recipients
our pensioners are living longer or is
it due to lower contributions
historically
just a brief answer will suffice
it's it's a number of issues i mean
every employer is assessed separately
and different employers have different
positions
um and that can be influenced by a
number of factors
the age profile of your staff generally
makes a difference because
if you have a younger staff
then you tend to be better funded than
if you have um
an older staff and that's to do with
changes in the scheme and to do with the
amount
of service that people have built up and
therefore
the the liabilities you'll have to pay
that and obviously the older
your staff group is the sooner you'll
have to meet um those liabilities
because they'll retire sooner
and therefore their their liabilities
will be discounted by slightly less
um so that's that's part of the equation
um some authorities have paid extra lump
sums into the fund at time and that help
at times and that has helped their
funding position but not every authority
is in a position to do that
so so there's a whole variety of reasons
why you might
be in a slightly different position to
other employers in the fund
okay thank you very much indeed for
those answers mark and thank you very
much for
spending your time to give a very
comprehensive and in-depth
view of the pensions thank you very very
much
thank you right um
we will now move on to item eight
reporting ongoing concern
to receive a report from the section 151
officer pages 17 to 24 on the agenda
pack
right uh thank you chair thank you
i'll just go proof briefly through the
key highlights from the report
um the going concern report is an
assessment of the authority's ability to
maintain its essential services for the
suitable future
kovid 19 along with recent um cuts to
central government pose a threat
obviously to the ongoing viability
financial availability of the council
so on on page 18 i refer to the current
financial position so the highlight from
the current
position for the year 2000 1920 we
actually
um reported a surplus of 151 000
and actually one of the key point is we
actually did actually put one million
pounds
into reserves after taking that surplus
generally the most of the money that
we've set aside to reserves is towards
our
capital program for our vehicle
replacement and general capital
replacement
however one of the key things is to look
forward rather than to look at the past
so looking forward and that's covered in
pages 19 to 20.
so the good news for torres district
council compared with a lot of
other councils is we're actually
predicting a break-even position
for the current financial year 2020-21
and this was reported to cnr i think on
the 7th of september
however particularly because of kovid 19
there's a great deal of uncertainty
about the council's finances over the
medium term um
when we last looked at the medium-term
financial strategy which was reported to
full council in february
2020 we had a deficit
over the period to 2024-25 of 1.2
million
with lots of caveats we're now expecting
that deficit to increase to 3.8 million
but there's lots of caveats
the full impact of kovid 19 and as yet
we don't know the level of
government funding we'll get over that
period and not likely to know
anytime soon really the full extent to
the government funding
um so the council has referred to
doesn't just have
revenue budgets we have capital
expenditure
and on page 21 we've got an approved
capital program 32.6 million
that's dependent upon the future high
street and submission being successful
with central government
and we have various sources of funding
most of them in the future of how we're
going to fund our capital programme
so we have contributions from our
revenue budgets every year we set
money aside from our revenue budgets
into capital reserves to fund
the vehicle replacement program and
general capital we have grant
contributions which help us fund our cap
program we have capital receipts
members have previously approved
borrowing for the council so we've got a
facility to go out and borrow money so
our new environmental center it will be
when it comes to pass
largely funded by external borrowing and
currently we top slice some of the
new homes bonus funding to set aside for
capital purposes
i think what's important for members to
note is that we've got 5.2 million
pounds already banked in capital
reserves at the end of the financial
year
which doesn't sound a lot when we've got
a capital program of 32.6 million
there's various sources of future
capital finance and they have different
degrees of certainty
so in most certain contributions and the
monies that we're already setting aside
from our revenue budgets
the approved borrowing and some schemes
like the future high street where we
will only go ahead
if the government approve it and we'll
have some grant funding accordingly
what's less certain in our funding of
our capital program
is new homes bonus we know the scheme
eventually is going to end
it's been extended another year and
capital receipts which by their nature
are variable
so the key point from the report is on a
simply looking under secured capital
funding basis we have a potential
shortfall on the capital program
over its life which goes to 2025 26 of 5
million pounds
so members need to be aware of that
obviously i think members will be aware
that in layman's term one of the key
criteria assessing whether you've
have them are going are going as soon as
your cash flow so on page 22
i refer to the cash flow and for
touristly for
this council we're not expecting any
significant cash flow issues at least
until march 2022
we're expecting to have circa two to
three million pounds in our bank account
in march 2022 and in all our reports the
government has government's been asking
us for information of the impact of
kovid 19
they are always asking do you have cash
flow issues and we're always reporting
no we don't have cash flow issues
we have sufficient resources to carry on
our key core and key services um i
wasn't going to maybe
labor the report because we have a full
agenda and it's the report is just for
noting but more than happy to take any
questions
right thank you very much indeed david
um it's an excellent report does anybody
wish
to make any comment
um right well in
view that um counselor claire hodgson
has put down i've read the going concern
report and discussed its contents with
the strategic manager
i'm satisfied with the information as
presented
and with the assurance given and
endorsed the report
so the recommendation is that we note
this report
if the committee is happy with that the
report is duly noted and we can move on
to the next item
thank you very much indeed item nine
changes
to external audit emphasis financial
resilience to receive
a verbal report from the section 151
officer back to you again david
uh yeah thank you i think actually um
this is somewhat of a duplication of
item 14 where our colleagues from grant
foreign
are going to give us an update i believe
on the redmond
report so i think rather than take away
their thunder
i think i'll leave it to our colleagues
saying grant falton's update so the
redmond report has recently been issued
and i think
there's a duplication of essentially the
gender item so i'll leave it to
i think it's alex i'll give us an update
item 14.
we'll wait for item 14 on that one thank
you very much indeed david
so we will move directly on to item
number 10
presentation of the annual governance
statement to
receive a report from the service
improvement officer pages 25 to 38
on your pack and a recorded vote will be
taken
after this item so over to you chris
thank you chair um the annual government
statement sets out um
the council's government's arrangements
for the year at the last meeting in july
we actually walked through the document
page by page and it hasn't changed since
then so i was not going to walk the
documents again today
um okay like he just said it's down to
having an approval document so it can be
signed up
with the accounts are there any other
questions on the document before we
have a vote
any questions anybody can answer craig
ruth yes
you have your hand up dying to a new
thank you
um in the report on page 33
it says last year we had 40 stage 1 and
15 stage 2
4 more customer complaints um i've got
nothing to compare that with
is that good or is that bad is it
improving is it getting worse
how does it compare to other authorities
um i'm not sure about those authorities
but certainly for those that's been
improving
um we used to get between 60 and 70
promo complaints a year
and last year was probably the best
you've had for a long time so
i think it's improving and can i ask
when did we last review how to make a
formal complaint
because i'm concerned about how easy it
is to make a complaint if that
you know customers have got a problem
obviously we don't want it to get to a
formal complaint but
um if they do need to complain how uh
when did we last review the procedure
uh we reviewed it in 2019 april 19
um updated the procedures then it's
available on the website
and if you live up to customer services
they'll just send you a copy of
the process and so we try and make it
available as possible really
and the other the other thing i wanted
to ask is where are most of the
complaints
which which section of our our services
are the complaints coming in to
um it's across the board i can't just
send you i did do a report in the
members bulletin a few months ago of
last year's complaints
i could send you a copy of that if you
like just showing me the service my
service
where they came from yeah i just
wondered if there was a collection
you know because it would highlight
there was a problem if there was more
in one section that's all thank you very
much
yeah it tends to change each year
and obviously we use learning points
from them and
feedback to the manager saying can we
change this and we do change procedures
to try and
minimize complaints thank you
okay thank you ruth um council hodgson
claire you have your hand up you would
wish to speak
to you oh yes please um i'm happy to
recommend this report subject to just a
couple of issues
uh on page
34
we refer to the northern burrows
it's only a minor typo but they're the
northern boroughs not the northern ones
and obviously later on in the report
when you
when you replicate this in the grant
thornton report
you'd have to adjust that as well um
page 36 uh
the bottom sort of box key services
um the impact on day-to-day operations
and the very last bullet point
some existing programs eg renovating
affordable housing
but we weren't renovating affordable
housing we were renovating hostel
accommodation
and temporary accommodation and
presumably
there was some impact on the delivery of
disabled facilities grants
so subject to
a very small tweak there i'm more than
happy to recommend this
if nobody else is okay i'll get them
thank you okay thank you very much
claire right if nobody else is uh
wishing to speak i'm happy to second
that from the chair
and i'll pass on to kirsty to make the
um recorded vote on the recommendation
subject to
the amendments being made by councillor
hudson
over to you kirsty thank you chair
councillor craigie or
councillor hackett
councillor heppel for councillor hudson
fall and councillor jones
four okay councillor james has left the
meeting
so that's now five four
thank you very much kirsty so we will
now
move on to item
in
[Music]
sorry yes presentation financial
statement to receive an update and
financial statement
2019-20 from the section 151 officer
pages 39-154
so if i hand you back to david
uh thank you chair um you'll be pleased
to know i've decided not to go through
page by page one all 105 pages of this
um these accounts were presented um
on the 28th of july to the audience and
governance committee
and there has been no changes to the key
statements
as to the accounts as a result the
external audit accounts there's only one
figure that has actually
changed in the account so i'll stand to
be corrected by my colleague alex from
grant fart and who will go through the
audit findings report
and the only figure that has changed has
been the external order fee which was
revised upwards by
3 000 pounds there was a polarity issue
on the cash flow statement and the
figures were right just the
the signs were um presented in a
slightly um
misleading way but the figures were
correct so it's probably rather than
me go on about the the statement
accounts in any great detail of course
nothing's changed as i referred to
earlier the council had a surplus of 151
thousand pounds
uh which was set aside to our transition
government fund reserve to meet the
pressures that we anticipate going
forward i think
i'll happily take any questions on the
final statements but i probably think it
might be more
beneficial for you to hear from alex on
the her findings of the
final accounts okay well without further
ado
as i don't see any hands raised in front
of me
um i will take you up on your suggestion
and we'll move forward to item 12
the isa 260 audit findings report
2018-19 and receive the report from
grant borneton
external auditors pages 146
to 170 and i'll hand over to you alex
thank you
thank you chair um so i wasn't going to
take you through page by page
of this audit findings report um
but the isis do require that i i bring
certain things to your attention
so if i kick off by looking at page 148
where we set out the the headlines from
the audit
um and obviously we refer in there to
covert 19
as you would probably expect us to do so
um and
i know that andy raised uh mentioned to
you the last audit committee
the fact that obviously we were working
at home um some of us went back into the
office last week but i think
given what boris is about to say tonight
we might be back at home again tomorrow
which will be interesting so we remained
largely working at home
and i think it's fair to say as a result
of that that does mean that the work
does take longer especially when you
couple that with the
um the requirements of the regulator
and certain key areas as well the work
that we need to do
it it is it has been taking it
significantly longer
in terms of the financial statements so
we set out there that you know we did a
lot of our work remotely during june
july august
some of the work is still ongoing
there's a small amount of work
around the pension fund and you've just
had obviously a long presentation
by the somebody from the devon pension
fund and i recognize the fact that our
colleagues who are auditing
the devon pensions and that work is
ongoing
um and in their defense i would say that
you know the work is taking longer
because remote working
um also because of the regulator
requirements but also key areas such as
mcleod
and what's known as experience as well
so there are some key issues that have
come up on the pension side this year
that impact not just on pension funds
but obviously
on your accounts as well and some of
those areas are still
being discussed at the moment with the
pension fund and the actuary we're also
completing our work around
uh property plants and equipment
and that we might refer there to some of
the opening balances testing that we're
actually required to do
pension property planting equipment big
big figure in your accounts
um and it's it's a valuation it's
subjective it's not an exact science
um but we're expected to look quite uh
quite a lot at it at how the figures
have come about
um in years gone by we would have just
been told a figure by the valuer and
just accepted it unfortunately we're not
allowed to do that anymore the regulator
expects to do far more
um and so that obviously has brings with
it both
frankly time and potentially a cost in
the long run as well
and so that's it in terms of kind of
where we are so moving over the
page on page 149 um
we refer there to the anticipated audit
report and we might refer to the fact
that
there will be an emphasis of matter
paragraph
in the opinion and this is fairly
consistent across
local authorities and what is
effectively doing is so your value
when they valued your property plans
equipment at the year end
they were advised by their own institute
rick's
that because of covet 19 the valuation
of properties was quite was fluctuating
quite significantly
so they put in what they called an
emphasis of matter
you've drawn attention to that in your
accounts um
around the valuation and because it's
such a significant obviously
you know ppe valuation your accounts are
such a large figure
we would re be remiss if we just um
ignored it
and therefore we'll also be putting in
an emphasis of matter
effectively all that does is draw the
reader's attention to something that
you've actually got in your own account
so it's not a qualification
i have to very clear about that it's
just about drawing the
leaders attention to that there will
potentially also be
an emphasis a matter around the pension
fund valuation as well
but obviously until the pension fund
audit has completed their work
we're unable to say exactly whether that
is the case
but again that would just be a case of
adding in a few more words into
our own emphasis of matter in terms of
value for money
um so we've updated our risk assessment
and we've looked at the key areas of
risk that we'd
identified earlier on in the year in our
audit plan
and we're happy that they're the
arrangements are in place within
torridge
we've not had to use any of our
statutory powers that are available to
us i'm pleased to say
and i think before i move on to the rest
of the report i'd just like to say thank
you really to the finance team i mean i
think
i think it's fair to say both producing
the accounts this year
and also ordering them as being very
hard
that were like
we've raised queries
that's for additional
i'm having a problem hearing you alex
would you just like to repeat the last
30 seconds of
what you were saying yes i just i was
just oh thank you
oh it says my internet connection is
unstable i don't i can't blame my son
for that because he's not home
so um i'd just like to say thank you to
the finance team actually
so they've been very responsive to our
queries
and i think i appreciate that a lot of
them have been working in the office
but they've been very understanding
about the fact that obviously we've been
working from home largely
so moving over to the rest of the report
so on page 150 we talked there about
materiality
same materiality figures that we brought
to you in our audit plan earlier in the
year
um and then the rest the next few pages
are looking at what we call the
significant audit risks
so there's they're the areas that we
focus on in the audit
um because potentially there are you
know there could be big areas
um large numbers or they could actually
be have
a as i say quite a significant
estimation
um involved with them so we focus in on
those
if i can then flick to um
if i'm going to if i'm going too quickly
please do stop me or i'm happy to take
obviously take questions as we go along
as well
so on page 1 5 8 we then um
look at other matters for communication
and there are areas that as i say under
the auditing
standards required to to bring to you as
though those charged with governance
um if we have any concerns around things
like fraud
or related parties or law and
regulations etc
there's nothing that i want to bring to
your attention in that section of the
report
um other responsibilities under the code
so the code of audit practice is
set by the national audit office and
that's set for
all local government and nhs bodies
and there's various things apart from
just giving the the opinion on the
accounts as various other areas that we
have to look at
so we look at things like your ags which
you've just been talking about
also the narrative report which is at
the start of the accounts
and just make sure that there's nothing
in there that is
um departs from what's actually in their
cats or actually is telling
telling us the story that we think well
no that's not toridge
so we do look at those and i'm pleased
to say that
no inconsistencies in in that work
um we also have to do what's known as
the special specified procedures around
whole of government accounts
um and my understanding that is that the
the auditor's guidance is still
outstanding
so even if we could finish the audit
today i couldn't issue the certificate
on the
um on the accounts anyway because as i
say that that piece of work will be a
very high level because you're
de minimis um we can't actually do at
the moment
over on page 160 onwards we talk about
the value for money arrangements and in
the next agenda item actually
i was going to talk a little bit not
just about redmond but just refer
as well to the the new valley family
arrangements going forward
but the key area that we looked at this
year was around financial sustainability
as you'd probably expect
a key issue for the public sector
generally
and obviously in the new covered world
actually will continue to be
a big issue for us to look at but in
this case we were looking back at 1920
and obviously a lot of the covid only
reflected the last couple of
weeks of the year probably have more of
an impact and i know david
davis talked a bit about going concern
um and covered some of that already
um so what i'd just like to draw out
really from that is
um it kind of feels like i'm telling you
the obvious thing and i know you already
know this but obviously
finances are are tight yes you do have a
level of reserves
but um you can't you know obviously once
used
the reserves disappear and you can't
keep using them
so it's about having a plan for future
years
2021 looks reasonable and obviously with
some of the covered funding hopefully
that will be helpful
but moving forward um the perhaps is a
greater challenge and it's um
it's inherent on the the council and the
councillors in particular
to make some potentially quite difficult
decisions about how they're going to
actually
um bridge any gaps in in the budget so
just just mention that at that stage
um i wasn't necessarily going to go
through
the rest of the report in any more
detail um on page six
eight we talk about the audit
adjustments which is david has already
referred to
are are fairly measly um and
there's just that one around the audit
fee but obviously i
just just want to mention obviously our
work isn't complete
and we're not expecting there to be any
significant changes as a result of the
work that we
still got to complete but i just say
that um this
this report isn't necessarily um totally
complete and got everything in it at
this stage
um but i'm you know i'm very pleased
with the number of audit adjustments
because obviously i think it's
reflective on
the finance team which is very positive
um so i was going to stop there but i
appreciate there's a bit of a cancer
through the audit finance reports i'm
happy to take any questions
okay does anybody wish to make any
questions or comments i
don't see any hands up
right um yes i'd like to go back
to something that was said fairly early
on and because of covid you're working
from home and the work takes longer
now from my understanding the audit
started
on the 19th of june so we're some
four months down the road and we haven't
got something to sign off today which
causes me grave concern because
essentially we have two such
journals open we have that year that
you're examining
and the present year and to me
that raises there is an element of risk
i'm not we have a very good accounts
team
but with two sets of accounts open
there is always the possibility however
remote that may be with a good
finance team that we have that some
figures
might get put in the wrong year's
accounts
and that is something we would want to
eliminate as soon and as quickly as
possible
so why has it taken this inordinate
length of time because in my five years
as chair of audit committee
we haven't taken this long to do an
audit now i do accept
you are going to tell me working from
home takes longer
but are you saying that you are not
getting the responses back
from our finance team in time because my
understanding is
whenever you've asked for something
you've had it promptly
so what is the reason for the time being
taken alex
thank you chair and i can't comment on
the the
having two sets of accounts open and i
don't know whether
david or steve want to actually come in
and comment on that because
my understanding is the ledger would
would be closed for
1920 and therefore um hopefully you
can't
actually journal stuff into to last year
and actually
if that is the case then that's a bit
worrying because we'd have to go back
over
some of the work that we've already done
potentially at this stage
um in terms of the work taking longer um
so i have to give david and his team uh
credit for the fact that they actually
gave us the
um a draft set of accounts it wasn't a
complete set of accounts a draft draft
set of accounts
earlier than they'd actually said that
they would do and that's because we had
at that time
people available to actually come in and
do the audit
um and i think we had about four or five
people at the time working on
on the audit um many of them obviously
we have a very tight time scale which to
work to even though the deadline is now
the end of november
um actually we are finding it is taking
significantly longer so
when once people have kind of done their
stint on torridge they move on to other
audits and they're working on those
um in terms of some of the delays um
i don't think from my understanding and
correct me if i'm wrong david
i don't think it's down to the finance
team i think some
some of the we have got some queries
outstanding around
um property planted equipment which i
believe is with the valuer
and the pension stuff and i think there
was a bit of a confusion about
who should be asking the actuary for
some of the queries that we actually had
and i think
potentially that could have been sorted
out a couple of weeks ago but it
fell between two stalls internally
within
grant thornton as opposed to um within
within the council
and the work is just genuinely finding
it's not it's not just unique at
torridge we are genuinely finding
the work is just taking significantly
longer and then once you've kind of
lost your slot in the in our planner
it's very difficult to get it back on
track
so oyster has been leading the um the
team this year
of course she's now early september she
went back to college
so now she effectively she's just
working on a part-time basis
um and to be fair to her i know she's
been working
a lot of evenings and a lot of weekends
to try and backfill
so i'm not sure that i'm wholly
answering your question because i think
i think it's i think it's fair to say
it's very difficult to know exactly why
it's taking longer
but my job is to scrutinize this and
find out why it's not taking longer
yeah well i think i think it's fair to
say it's not unique to torridge because
that's what we
so obviously when we did the nhs
accounts back in
april may they all we all thought
okay we've got this extension to the end
of june that's great but we've still
found that most of the accounts were
still being done end of june
um and i think it was just that [ __ ]
it's just
it's the sheer volume of work which um
in order to appease the regulators
has increased exponentially and when i
come on to
to talk about redmond and the next
agenda item
um hopefully if some of his
recommendations are taken up that would
be
helpful um i think um so it's a sheer
waste of work and it's just the people
working working from home and having to
ask for additional
assurances over you know where did that
number come from
can i see that bank statement and
actually being able to verify some of
that
information so what i'm seeing is
we're paying more for a slower service
which would
in some ways elevate the risk what i do
i bring david hayes in here
and maybe he'd like to just make a
comment i see you've got your hand up
david
yeah yes thank you chair sorry i just
wanted to allay
alex's fears really um in the first
instance
what happens is we have
the financial year 2000 and 1920 we have
the potential to post journals and the
reason we normally don't close it down
we normally close it when you say
you're good to go alex you've signed off
you give us your audit opinion
i'm going well at the conclusion of this
meeting i'm going to have a conversation
with my colleague renu actually does the
mechanics of that
and see that we can let's roll it
roll the year forward and so that
potential for somebody to inadvertently
post a journal to the old financial year
is eliminated we've never done it yet
but it whilst the financial year is open
within the legit there's always an
outside rare possibility but we would
capture it that's not an issue
so that's not um a massive fear but it's
just
generally we wait until you say here's
our opinion you don't have to change any
of the figures well at the moment
from what you're saying i probably won't
have to change any of the figures if
there's any change in your odd opinion
might be a little bit wording
regarding some uncertainty within the
pension valuations maybe a property
um et cetera where i'd have a slight
um thing um alex is um i think
oh she's done remarkably well in very
difficult times
this is our audience she did a
remarkable job being so young and
we've only maybe two or three years in
the role i thought she did a remarkable
um job and all credit to her
the only thing that's a slight issue i
find is when we're talking about some of
these pp and q
inquiries i think we've answered some of
them
last week but they came they were quite
late they were the things
you could have asked us four weeks ago
five weeks ago and we could have
answered them
and perhaps that's because the person
concerned was working on another
um audit and then just these things that
little things had been missed
so i acknowledge things have taken
longer we can't show your files so we
it takes longer for us because we've got
to dig out files attend
there's administrative issues i've
always have to create zoom things so you
can actually physically see the
downloading file but i just like to be
recognized that
it you know we feel like we've been
audited for three months essentially
you know there's other things we've been
needing to
get on been getting on with in the
meantime but um anyway pass on
i mean in fairness you know you've cast
on your very kind comments about the
finance team i'd certainly
like to feed back to some of your
colleagues particularly oshie and
and her colleagues who've been you know
i know oh she's worked late because i've
seen some of the time some of those
emails have come back to me
and how quickly she has responded
personally thank you
um coming coming back to the issue of
the pension um surely there must be
arrangements
in-house where one department in grant
thornton
can make an enquiry to another
department
and just say look have you an issue with
the pensions at torridge it's
it's a you know say it's falling down
between two stalls
and it's causing a delay in us being
able to sign off these accounts is
really not acceptable
would you like to comment on that please
alex
yeah so i mean we obviously do talk to
them we write formally to the pension
fund auditor
again that's all governed by um auditing
standards and the requirements on us and
what we have to actually do
um so we we have done that we as i say
we're waiting for their
until they've done their audit we can't
actually get their their assurances
what happened in terms of falling down
between two stalls
was that one of the um the managers
within the southwest
wrote to the actuary on behalf of a
number of different clients to get some
responses
um and my understanding is that
unfortunately the actuary was
unhappy we thought it was the best
approach because we were asking the same
question
of the same actuary um and we just do
once but do it for a number of different
authorities
unfortunately they this actually was not
very keen on that
and asked us to do it individually by um
by clients
um and that was only picked up fairly
recently that that needed to actually
be done so um because we do need to go
and i have my understanding because i
know
and andy's the manager has actually
emailed david this morning
um and the actuaries actually said could
the um
the request actually come from the
client rather than through ourselves i
don't think they'd like us to go to them
direct
um so that's sort of you know some it's
a very unfortunate but actually that's
just
the way it's actually happened this year
normally we probably wouldn't have quite
so much
correspondence with the actuary but
because of some of the big
pension issues like mcleod and
experience
and the various other legal cases that
are going on it has meant
quite a lot of touring and throwing with
the actuary to actually
establish what the issues are
you know do we have the assurances we
need we talk about big numbers do we
have the assurances we need etc
yeah so it's something that really
there needs to be a review in-house with
grant thornton as to how to handle this
so it isn't delayed
from torridge's point of view because at
the end result
is that it's affecting the sign off date
for our accounts
quite dramatically i think in
in this particular instance in terms of
the falling between the two managed i
think that's just a very unfortunate
thing that actually happened this year
somebody was trying to do
minimize the um correspondence with the
actuary
um and actually that that didn't work
for whatever reason so i think that's
just an unfortunate thing that thing
that we can actually learn
learn from um going forward i think it's
unfortunate as to say that we have this
number of issues around
you know mcleod experience etc etc which
actually mean that we their interaction
and the regulator requirements the reg
the actual interaction with the the
actuary and the pension fund is
significantly
greater than it has been in previous
years okay well i won't i won't labor it
any
further but i think um you can see that
things would have to change for next
year i think because there's been
[Music]
it's been a far from satisfactory result
for us
because we have had an excellent set of
accounts and thank you again for david
and your team
right um so item 12
we just have to note at this stage
item 13 the approval of the financial
statements for the year ending the 31st
of march 2020.
the committee to approve the financial
statements for the year ending the 31st
of march 2020
and to authorize the signing of the
letter of representation the financial
statements by the chair of the meeting
the annual government statement by the
chair of the audit and governance
committee
and the statutory finance officer pages
171-173
and a recorded vote will be taken
right
we are not in position to move forward
on that are we
okay
in this instance with regret we have to
move on
we move on to item 14 is is that
thank you very much item 14 the
independent review of local authority
financial support
alex has raised her hand yes alex please
sorry chair all i was going to say was
there's nothing to stop you actually
approving the accounts and the letter of
rap
and accepting the audit finding this
report but obviously
um but having some kind of proviso that
should the accounts materially change
that either they come back
through the whole committee or they come
back to you as chair
um you could could do it that way should
you should you choose
to do so
i will seek advice of one of my offices
on this
um either david or steve
as to what should actually happen
um chair i'd probably go with alex's
suggestion because
from what we've referred to this it's
unlikely we'll have the material changed
to the accounts
there may be in a narrative sense
there'll be some
adjustment to be made but i don't see
anything at this juncture would mean
there'd be a material change to the
account so
it's not like there's an outstanding
like last year perhaps was an
outstanding thing about the impact of
mcleod alex
where that could have come in late and
changed the figures
so it maybe kills one bird now rather
than later
okay on your advice as 151 officer i
will
take that recommendation from the chair
if i could seek a seconder please
if somebody council do you wish to
second
i do thank you very much indeed
so i will pass you back to kirsty to
take the recorded vote thank you kirsty
thank you chair yes councillor craigie
or councillor hackett for
councillor heppel four councillor hudson
councillor james four
that's five for chair
thank you very much indeed thank you
kirsty so that is
approved we will now move on to
item 14 which is the independent review
of local authority financial reporting
external audit
and to receive a report from grant
thornton
external auditors over to alex thank you
thank you chair and there was one key
area that i was going to mention which
is the redmond review
and i was also going to mention the
change in the code of audit practice as
well
um possibly because they're sort of
interlinked
and have some similar repercussions um
in terms of the redmond report review
it came out um i think it was the 8th of
september
um and it's been well heralded
it's been in a lot of the local press
um and in the various sort of public
finance and things like that
um it's been a review that's been
ongoing for a while
led by tony redmond so very well thought
of in his field
just very brief precis of what the
report comes out with so the report
comes out with a number of
recommendations
which will go to mhclg
for them to decide what to do going
forward
i think it recognizes the fact that
actually
in effect public sector audit in its
current sense
is slightly broken and i think it
probably
plays out some of the conversations we
had around about
this time last year around non-delivery
of audits
fees etc etc so tony redmond has spoken
to
lots of different people if you read the
full report you can see who you've
spoken to
obviously audit suppliers psaa who
obviously appoints your auditor
national audit office and various other
people as well who you know
incept for etc key recommendations that
he
um has suggested one is the first is the
new regulator
um and he suggested something called the
office of local audit and regulation
um which would replace the frc the
financial reporting council
who are a current regulator and also
psaa
what he's very clear about is this is
not a return
to the audit commission it would be a
small number of people
but they would have very you know
similar-ish um functionality to
the the commission as it as was um
the argument for the new regulator is
really that the frc is very corporate
focused
um and some of the areas that they ask
us to look at and focus on
really the average um stakeholder in the
public sector is
is not really that interested so two key
you know two key areas of estimation
i've talked about them before in the
accounts around
property plans and equipment your assets
in effect
and pensions and actually
joe public probably don't really care
how much you know if you've got council
has is how much they're worth how much
your
your you know your schools are actually
worth because actually at the end of the
day
what they're really worried about is the
services that you're providing are you
providing value for money
um and actually how much it costs them
in terms of their council tax
those are the key areas um and
unfortunately we've lost sight of that
and we we're focusing on areas that
potentially some might say perhaps we
should we shouldn't
be looking at so that's looking at a new
regulator
there's also talking about um scope to
increase fees
um his view is that the current fee
structure for local audit
needs to be revised um and making sure
that adequate resources are deployed to
meet the full
extent of local audit requirements and
again i think that plays out some of the
conversations we had
last year and some of the conversation
we've just had which is basically
we don't have adequate resources to
actually
do those do those audits and when i'm
talking about grant thornton
i'm talking about the profession as a
whole people don't want to do public
sector audit anymore
they did in my day 30 years ago
they were very keen on doing it they're
really interested in doing it
it's a very different job now it's very
hard we've talked about some of the
hours that some of my team are working
which is not just not sustainable um
given the fees the the race the bottom
unfortunately
has created really big issues in terms
of
the audit suppliers so it's looking to
potentially
change that going forward they're also
looking at a move back to an end of
september deadline again recognizing
that end of july
last year i think it was something like
40 only 40
of local authorities actually hit that
deadline um
so it's clearly not sustainable um and
perhaps
you know it does it does it really need
to be the end of july
it's also talking about simplifying the
accounts i mean i know david's just
skimmed through the report the accounts
themselves but if you compare the
accounts with
a lot of corporate entities the accounts
of local authorities
are extremely long and extremely oblique
um even to somebody like myself who's
you know done public sector audit for
donkey's years
some of those those notes and those
accounts are really very difficult to
actually follow and actually work out
what they're really telling me
as a taxpayer within a local area what
is that
really telling me about how my council
is actually working
and what does that really mean so
there's some talk about trying to
make those a lot simpler going forward
and also recognizing that you yourselves
have a role
in terms of improving governance and
reporting and i think it's reflecting on
the fact that actually
governance in a lot of local authorities
is not what it should be
and not as good as it should be
unfortunately um
and obviously thinking about you know
how that might
that might play out going forward and
they're also talking about developing
um a sort of audited account summary
document and i know this is something
that a lot of local authorities have
done in previous years
summarizing um what's actually in the
accounts because as i say
the average joe public it is not going
to understand
i'd be interested to know if anybody
actually reads local authority accounts
sadly
i know we all spend a lot of time
looking at them um
but actually do people actually look at
them um because
they're as i say pretty oblique and
quite difficult to actually follow
whereas if there was a
10-page summary perhaps that would be a
lot easier
so that's that's the redmond review as i
say those recommendations
of being going to mhclg be interested to
see what happens as a result of
of those recommendations going forward
um i think
genuinely there's quite a lot of support
around a lot of those areas
i think i think people just recognize
that actually the
the whole local audit regime just isn't
working
um and you know i know we've had some
very difficult conversations about
failure to deliver
quality of staff the fees etc this is
played out in
a lot of local authorities you're not
unique
by any stretch of the imagination um and
i
appreciate you have to ask those
questions it's very difficult for me to
actually
have to to be able to respond because
i'm trying to defend
frankly the indefensible which is which
puts us all in a very difficult position
so that's the redmond review i'll just
very quickly talk about the
the change in the code of audit practice
so the code of audit practice is set by
the national audit office
as i mentioned earlier it covers both
local authorities and the nhs
it was laid before parliament in april
2020
and actually is applicable from 2021
financial years onwards
key change within that is around valley
for money
so we'll be looking at arrangements in a
lot more detail
in 2021 and once we get some more detail
obviously i'll be sharing it with with
david
and yourself so that you you can see
what the areas that we're looking at
understandably financial sustainability
is there a key area for us to actually
look at governance as well which is
interesting because it sort of
replicates what's in the redmond review
as well
so key areas to look at going forward
there won't be an
opinion per se on the value for money
arrangements
it'll be a commentary um more detailed
probably a higher level in terms of
the skill mix of the people actually
delivering that and that will bring with
it
additional additional fee and that's
something that's currently being
discussed
with psaa as to how that will um
actually play out because i think it's
talking about quite a considerable
amount
more work than we're currently doing
around value for money
but the idea of that really is to add
some value
um so again so the stakeholders can
actually
look at their local authorities and take
a view on
are they doing the things that they they
should be doing in the key areas and do
they have those arrangements in place
so that's all i was going to say on the
code happy to take any questions
right um if anybody wishes to comment
from the committee otherwise
i'm happy with it and it counts and
claire would you
you've got your hand raised yes okay
um um thank you alex for that i
i would welcome any sort of briefing
notes you've got on the redmond review
i've
tackled it twice um going through it
uh it seemed the message that came out
to
me was we must
present things to our
constituents our council taxpayers
in a much more straightforward manner
we must present information that they
want to
receive rather than as you say
very lengthy documents that even for
those
employed in the profession are at times
a little bit of a challenge
i'm quite interested in what you've just
said about
you're not going to be asked for opinion
you're going to give a commentary
now can you can you explain to me as a
bearer of simple brain
the difference between opinion and
commentary
is commentary more of an observation of
where we're going
rather than whether we're getting it
right or not
that's probably a fair summation so the
the opinion at the moment is
is binary so it's you've either got the
arrangements in place
or you haven't um and obviously you know
quite often having
conversations with clients where where
the arrangements aren't in place because
we have to go obviously one way or the
other that can be very contentious
but the commentary as you say is more to
kind of set out
to draw a conclusion if you like in
terms of these are the arrangements and
do we think they're
they're adequate or not but we won't
actually be giving of
a formal conclusion does that
sorry does that help well yes it does it
it just for me
and you're saying this is going to be
more costly
than giving an opinion and to me it's
um you're not going to be accountable
for a commentary whereas you might be
more held more accountable
for an opinion so it baffles me as to
why it's more expensive to give
something
that you are less accountable for but
perhaps that's me being a little cynical
i don't know i don't expect you to reply
to that because you're probably
biting your tongue so but it's just an
observation
thank you
right thank you claire um
right so we note oh sorry
councillor craigie ruth would you like
to speak you have your hand raised
over to you claire
thanks i just wondered if it said
anything about how often we have to
value our assets because i think that
takes a lot of time and it's not always
um you know time well spent and do we
have to still
do going concern reports
shall i pick that one up and then david
might want to chip in
so the um the code of the cipher code of
practice says that you should
value your i can't with the exact pricey
but it effectively value your assets um
as often as you think you need to so
obviously in times when values are going
up considerably or down considerably
you may wish to value them more often
but it has to be at least every five
years
um the problem with not valuing them
actually is that
um not getting a formal valuation is
that the finance team then have to make
an assessment
of actually whether the evaluation that
was done two
three four years ago is still valid and
sometimes that can actually take
longer and create more work and more
challenge
than if actually if you got a value in
into doing
them yourselves in terms of going
concern my understanding
is that um i think there might be
something coming out and
going concerned shortly but at the
moment yes local authorities are still
and nhs
still need to consider that whether
they're actually going concerns or not
and actually do that assessment so
david's paper earlier on in the agenda
is extremely helpful because obviously
he's giving you the assurance that
the councillors are going concerned but
he's also giving us the assurances that
the council is
going concern and that paper can be you
know
some places do extremely long lengthy
papers david's paper was
was was succinct and i think kind of hit
all the
all the things i would expect him to hit
and as i say gave us
quite a great deal of assurance that the
council is indeed a going concern
i know there's always an argument well
in the public sector
is anybody going to let local
authorities actually fail
but we you know there are instances
where local authorities do
fail and have services taken off them
you've got the examples of
northamptonshire etc
um so you know i think it's still valid
to do some form of going going concern
assessment
until somebody tells it and tells us we
don't have to do it
thank you right okay
well i'm happy to note that report and
thank you very much
alex for giving it to us so we'll now
move on to
item number 15 which is the
effectiveness of the audit committee
and to receive a report from the devon
audit partnership manager
so over to rob and it's page 174 to 179
on agenda pack
rob um thank you sharon good afternoon
members
um your relatively um short report
actually it's an annual assessment that
we complete
just to make sure that the audit
committee is working effectively
um and we measure that effectiveness
against a safer
self-assessment so on pages 176 179
there's a table setting out what's
expected to be in place for the unit
committee
and our assessment of that we've done it
for a few years now
and in a way the the uh little creeks
and and groans that we found in
uh early years have been ironed out now
um so i think you've got a pretty good
robust um procedures in place
um and hence we've got a um a reasonably
clean report for you
um mrs pleasing i think that's good um i
think the only thing that we um
wanted to raise i think is on um in the
recommendation on page 175
um i think it's recognizing that we've
moved since
since um march to meet him virtually
using um zoom and then a lot of other
councils use teams
and really it's seeking your thoughts
your comments and views and how
effective that technology has been
in enabling you to discharge your
function as a
the audit committee so in essence a
clean report in terms of the mechanics
of what
should be in place we believe is in
place so that's that's pleasing
um and then we thought it'd be some
benefit and
um if time allows i do appreciate you
quite late in the agenda
there's any thoughts on how um this
remote working um is
is working and um is anything it needs
to be improved upon
cancer craig um ruth you'd like to speak
first
well uh sorry i wasn't going to answer
that whether i think the zoom yeah i
think the thing meetings haven't been
too bad
but what i was going to ask is when are
we going to have to do a carbon order
alongside our
financial audit each year
i think we're going a bit of peace don't
we with that one
well i think it's part of the governance
is it not but we should be looking at
um i mean we look at all the other
issues
i think we should be looking at the
carbon audit too
um i think we actually got an
environmental audit in the plan um
this year as an internal audit review um
i think what you were asking maybe is a
question about how is a
a statement from the organization about
being carbon neutral
or moving towards being carbon neutral
would that be the question
yeah i just you know there must be some
measurements of
i should have thought the government
ought to be introducing it
i don't know whether they are but i
would have thought they ought to be
so that they can get a review of you
know
um how all the things that we're doing
you know how we're doing towards moving
towards being carbon neutral
it's got the measurement is what i'm
saying i you know
in order to see whether you're moving in
the right direction you need measurement
don't you
in the absence of any other officers
being in a better position
i'm happy to try to find out um
what requirements there may be on the
horizon um
and feedback unless anybody else is
better placed
now that that would be great if you
could do that yeah
right chris you've got your hand raised
is it in response to this
um yeah um yeah let me go ahead chris
my understanding is the climate change
working group we're looking at this uh
janet's team
where the council haines are looking at
measures for the council already so
that's actually in progress with college
with the climate change working group
okay right thank you thanks chris
um cancer jones that you would like to
come in there
so over to you dave thank you chair just
on the issue of the remote working i
personally think that it
that it works fine i think with a
committee of this size
we're able to have the disco we need to
have
and i think that to carry on remotely
would make sense obviously it saves
um everyone having to travel in
especially when we have a lot of
external people involved as we do today
so no i i'm very happy with this
arrangement and i hope that
post covert if we have the um ability to
if the government allows it to continue
that we hold committees like this
virtually thank you okay
thank you dave thank you all right does
anybody else wish to speak
right okay um from
from my point of view yes i think these
committees are working well
virtually um however when you sometimes
need to scrutinize things
it's good to have somebody in front of
you to
i think you can it's always harder to
read the body language
when you're working remotely and
sometimes
when you do have issues that you want to
delve down deeply with
it's always better to have somebody in
front of you
but that is a personal opinion um
right so we at this stage note the
report
don't we so we duly note it and move on
to
item number 16 which
is the audit reports issued to date
which have been previously circulated
and their page 180-195
so i think we can be fairly brisk with
these because we have seen them
um previously to this meeting
but if you'd just like to briefly go
through them chris
um i'm happy for that to go forward
thank you the floor is yours
um maybe i should take through take your
sights and
right okay and all of these check
as you actually write this please sorry
yes i apologize
it is you your name against them so
since the last committee we've issued
you with um free
uh internal reports and as you're
rightly saying the full report has been
provided to the audit committee
and on page 181 uh you can see that
we've given substantial assurance for
vat
and reasonable assurance for um
environmental protection and risk
management
um and you'll see in the boxer below
there we give um
the opinions range range from
substantial
reasonable limited and no assurance
we've actually adopted these sit for
recommended insurance opinions
so that's going to be reasonably
consistent there across the
public sector so that should be um
aiding you to neighbors compared with
other organizations
should you wish to and in uh true to
form we provide a summary of the
findings
in this paper but as you say chair
um two things i mean generally there's a
sound assurance opinion been given each
of those areas action plans have been
issued and we're pleased that
management's responding to those action
plans
um and you have previously seen the
detailed reports
so let's take any questions yeah thank
you
it looks all very green which is very
reassuring for us
um so any questions from anybody
otherwise we will just simply
note cancer hudson claire if you'd like
to speak
hi thank you very much um i'm i'm
looking
at uh the risks management issues and
it's an area which is of interest to me
um i think page 193
out you've outlined it's how important
it is
to ensure that sufficient time is given
during meetings
when something comes up in a part two
where details haven't been provided
until the meeting to actually have time
to consider
the issues and not just have an eject
reaction
so i think you know we need to
to ensure that uh people are briefed
at least with regard to what is going to
be discussed
um and you do say that we ought to be
having some further
training you reckon um going forward
for risk management now i think it's
quite important
that members understand
risk management issues i think some
people think they understand risk
and mitigation very few activities can
contain no risk at all are risk-free
most of our services have risks
but it's understanding how we level the
mitigation
when i became lead member of
corporate resources i found it very
useful
uh going through people's everybo the
services
business plans and the risk issues that
have been raised with delivery of those
services
and i wonder if we should be encouraging
lead members to
have more knowledge about the risks of
those individual services
so that we spread the knowledge of what
is happening with regard to
individual service risks which may well
not
be escalated up to the corporate risk
register
but they are equally i won't say equally
as important
they are important and i think as
members we must make sure that we
are evaluating uh the risk management
register because obviously with covid
we have faced significant risks with the
additional duties
and being able to deliver some of the
requirements that have been
forced upon us at
a very short notice we've got
more money to hand out we've got to find
the resources to do that
as a local authority obviously i don't
think it will be such a huge
impact as
the business grants where but there's
still
significant processes to go through so
i think as members we need to be
much more aware and whether this is
through
training or whether this is through
making sure that
we as an audit committee look at that
risk register i think
technically correct me if i'm wrong mr
chairman we
see it usually once a year the corporate
risk register should not see it at every
meeting
i think it comes out at mainly every
meeting i know it's not on this agenda
but we do see it
practically every night and i'll put it
like that can i can i be assured that
we put it on our forward plan and make
sure that it is involved
at every meeting for an update because
the
um the arena in which we're
uh working is changing so rapidly
that we need to be aware at least at all
our meetings i think
thank you okay
right with the absence of any other
further hands raised
we will note the reports that we've
previously seen
and move on to item 17 which is progress
with agreed actions
to receive a report from the service
improvement officer page 196-201
and back again to you chris this time
thank you chair um as the internal
reports are published we
enter all of the agreed actions onto a
database and track them through to
completion
um this just kind of provide you with an
update on
on progress if you look on page 198
there's a summary page there um so since
we actually posted to committee i think
it's back in january on this
there's been um 14 new in agreed actions
and management we've actually completed
49 actions in that period
so quite a lot of focus has been made um
in that box the orange box you'll see
there's 11 first extensions where things
haven't been completed
i'll talk through those in a minute
they're mainly co-vigilated
it says that there's two missed
deadlines this is two historical
activities
um one we covered on the action plan
which was the safeguarding
um protocol um so we covered that with
an action plan
the other one was our clinical waste
contract
um and i know that she hates speeding
discussion with north southern council
and they are still awaiting um
information back from the county council
on this
so that's again still outstanding um
on that page you'll see there's one high
risk um action outstanding
and that is the actual um asset
management plan
which is due to be completed back in
december that was actually in the
governance statement
if i walked in for a lot for the ones
which we've given extensions for explain
um
first of those at least on page 199 the
first of those was a
two of the tree protection strategy um
this got delayed due to the kobe work
but it's actually in progress
that's just been extended to next month
so this one should be done soon
um the next two are to do with your
protection requirements
and there's just a delay though we're
waiting for a report for the planning
advisory service
once you've had that so like a third
party delay there
that work will be done the bottom of the
page there are the trigger points that
section one
or six agreements again we're ready for
the completion of another piece of work
there that'll be done in december
then that can be carried out on page 200
um the first one there was measured
planning exercises which which couldn't
happen because of covid
and the next one is northern burrows
management plan
um and what they want to do is just
delay doing the plan until they've got
the new
uh northern borough century in place
which made sense to me that then
it's going to be quite different anyway
the next one was again the data
protection training
and the trade is not available at the
moment due to covered
uh the housing options action uh
that was basically due to delay due to
capacity and the teams were very busy
they've now got some help they've got
some helpful customer services now
they're doing some scanning for them so
once that's done i can get get on with
that one
and the harbour bylaws this went to the
whole board last week
and it's great for to see an archivist
for approval now so that one's nearly
nearly done
then the last jump is 201 um
this is just adding to his altitude very
similar actions um
which is resources the property team
they're kind of in progress
so most of those ones were kind of
extended because
of kind of covered stroke resource
issues but they're all kind of
happening are there any questions on
those
that's a craigie so ruth if you'd like
to
thank you thank you very much
um i'm not very happy about the tree
strategy
being put off again um i understand we
haven't got a tree
protection officer and and that the the
orders are taking up to a year
to put to to bring about um
when are we going to get a tree tree
person
i don't know what you call them tree
protection
and why why is the strategy delayed
because of covid surely to write a
strategy you just sit down and ride it
i think it's due the actual tree work is
now within the planning team
um so there's a dedicated officer doing
it i think they've just been very very
busy in planning
and this didn't take priority when i do
the planning work to do
like i said it's actually nearly done
from what um sean houghton told me it
should be done by the end of october
um so it's actually what it's actually
nearly done
i think it's really important that we
have a proper tree strategy
overall not just protecting the trees
that you know
with tree prep protection orders but
looking at
trees overall i mean it's something
we're trying to
increase and if we can't even protect
the ones we've got
then i don't think we do very well
the whole tree preservation order
business
okay we did have a tree protection
officer in place and he did update all
of the different agreements
and he's put everything onto the system
so the idea is that now the planning
office could manage that going forward
sorry if i could just come back on that
instead of waiting for the public to
come
forward and say they want a tree
preservation order on we should be going
out and actually positively looking for
trees
that shall be preserved we should be
proactive and we're not
i it is a sort of sore point with me at
the moment
thanks yeah i think that'll be difficult
we've got 300 square miles of land to
look after
and no dedicated staff so that would be
very difficult the council to do
right okay
thank you ruth thank you chris right any
other comments to make
right we we note the report there and
julie move on to item number 18 which is
the ags review of the governance
database principle c
and back to you uh chris for your report
pages 202 to 208
okay well then sit for providers with
guidelines
on the governor's principles um and we
have a database where we try and provide
evidence that we have each of those
different guidelines um
we have a rolling program of looking at
this committee looking at the different
parts of the database and that's making
you have to look at principles c
do you have defining outcomes in terms
of sustainable economic social
environmental benefits
so on pages two or four onwards
i've taken an extract from our database
to talk through
um now there's three main columns here
the first one is the um
the requirements you're supposed to have
the second column is what
suggests we have in place then the third
big column is
our evidence of what uh torridge have in
place so
part one of this is defining outcomes so
if we just go down this um
h2o4 um we need a vision based on
corporate and service planning
and our evidence services we've got a
strategic plan which members
and officers work together to do um
we have individual service plans and we
have a
way of reporting that back to members
next one is about community engagement
and involvement
and we have a common strategy a
consultation strategy
a media policy and a social media policy
then i've given examples of the high
street fund consultation events
and the local plans consultation showing
we do these things
um things like when there was a climate
change person outside the building
office right now i met them and spoke
about the climate change
of course we're going to look like
cultural shows as well to meet the
public
so we do as much you can in terms of
community engagement
um corporate service plans yes we have
different business plans for each
service area
onto page 205 it talks about having a
community strategy
um we tend to do press releases um
to advise of any consultation events and
put them on social media as well
um we try and make sure we contact
different stakeholders during each
consultation we take customer feedback
in 1010 services and different services
um
the next one is a regular report in
progress which is our quarterly business
reports committee down the bottom there
is performance trends
each year actually put together
benchmark reports comparing turrets with
our
uh the most 15 similar council which i'm
just kind of nearly completing at the
moment
this year miss magic protocols
we have a strategy in the process we
have a mismanagement group which means
quarterly
and a risk map and then on page 206
it's all about quality standards for um
service plans
each service plan has done the different
measures in place
and i've processed the competing demands
within the economy
um that's always by the strat plan
um which we're consulting at the moment
uh we also take on formal complaints and
we get a report from numbers man how are
complaints we should come to them
um and then there are obviously members
setting the budgets for each year
prioritizing where the money should be
spent so in terms of debating outcomes
um i'd kind of take those off saying we
actually meet the september amendments
the second one was actually about
sustainable economic social and
environmental benefits
as i said we should have a capital
investment and that's set out in our
medium term financial strategy
um carter program should be there we
actually have a
cut program report it's used for council
i take a recommendation from cnr capital
investment strategy which we have
um page 207
um this next two of um helping members
make decisions
so all of our kind of country reports
include sections on
risk risk and legal and financial
applications
um
so we actually you know things like the
um future
street fund that went to full council
there was a full kind of an asset in
there the financial implications and
everything
when it went to the community so there's
minutes published to the public
and decisions are published for cnr
um recording decision making and
spotting materials again that's
um strategic plan and helping counselors
by giving them information they need the
decision making we have protocols for
consultations that have no constitution
and finally on page 208 it's about um
protocols for their access and statutory
guidance um
again our committee reports have
different heritage in there
we have reports critical and guidance we
have an important diversity policy
an actual website has a lot of
information about website accessibility
so we kind of try and help people who
are visually impaired
hearing impaired and there's a whole
host of different accessibility there
on the website so i'd kind of think in
terms of what cypher wants us to do
for and this kind of
principle c we actually meet the
requirements to ask of us
if you've got any questions on there or
anything else you think should be in
there please please ask away
okay thank you very much chris
does anybody wish to make any comment on
the
the presentation otherwise we duly note
it
you know we get a hundred percent
on all the three items going
through and a strong
green and torres does it's keen to be
green it's our slogan
and i think we proved it from that
report
uh council hodgson you really wish to
speak so over to you
just just uh yes obviously we we've got
a lot of entries against the
objectives um it's just some of those i
think
it's yes we do it but how often do we do
it
um you know i noted on the first page
the consultation regarding the local
plan
we're going to be probably going through
um revisions to that and further
consultations needed
so this is something that should be a
living document
i presume and as
we go through it to actually update the
dates
of our actions so that it it stays a
living document
um evidencing that we're achieving these
objectives
um because otherwise it's well we did it
once
but we don't need to do it again but it
is going to be an ongoing thing
so i think we need to note that as well
as noting what we're doing but other
than that
you know it is commendable that we're
actually meeting all those areas
so thank you okay thank you just respond
on that
yeah to respond on that one i actually
create a new database each year
just in the awesome and i go through and
make sure we've got evidence
for the current commentary here to meet
the support the actual governance
statement
so happiness doubted you at all
uh i'm quite sure you're very efficient
on this
thank you
right okay so we'll note item 18
and move on to item
19 which is the forward plan on page 209
um i think it's fairly comprehensive
unless we have anything to add to it
that we wish to change
we're we're happy to take it as read
yes okay so that's the forward thing
yes certainly claire sorry um
you did make uh some inference that we
might require a further meeting
would that be a single item agenda right
that was to sign off the accounts which
we've actually done
which which we yes which we've done
um right so we don't
if you'd like to um just
no i'll speak to you outside this i
think okay speak to you again
uh but could could we add
um i think there is some suggestion that
we're going to have a sort of covid
report
um at the end of this financial year
about the impact
and an analysis of everything
so should we be looking at that in
cycles seven
if it's coming again i'll leave that or
if the code is it end of the financial
year under the
um the calendar year
okay thank you thank you right so
having debt with item 19
we do not have a closed section
on item 20 so that is the end of the
meeting
thank you all very much for attending
and thank you
our external contributors um
we've had a good meeting so thank you
and goodbye
thank you